>> Jennifer Cutting:
I'm Jennifer Cutting,
Folklife Specialist at the
American Folklife Center.
It's September 20th, 2018
and we are here a few hours
before our big concert tonight,
which is the American Folklife
Center's Homegrown series
special Archive challenge
sampler concert that's happening
tonight at 7:30 in the
Coolidge Auditorium and one
of the artists we have with
us is Elena & Los Fulanos.
Elena Lacayo is with
us here in the studio
for just a short
little interview.
How are you doing Elena?
>> Elena Lacayo: I'm great.
>> Jennifer Cutting: Your
sound check sounded great.
>> Elena Lacayo: Thank you.
>> Jennifer Cutting: Looking
forward to hearing you guys.
I guess the first
question I want to ask you,
you're the only Spanish
language performers we have
in tonight's lineup.
Where did you grow up and
when did you start singing
and playing?
>> Elena Lacayo: So I was
born in the U.S. I was born
in New Orleans, but my
parents had just gotten here,
it was the '80s and Nicaragua
was going through a Civil War,
which is where my
parents are from.
And in '92 when the -- well,
the war ended kind of in '90,
most of the conflict and
in '92 we moved back.
So I was about eight years old
and we moved back to Nicaragua
and lived there from
eight to 18.
>> Jennifer Cutting:
Where in Nicaragua?
>> Elena Lacayo: In Managua.
My family is from Leon mostly
but we spent the
time in Managua.
And I started -- I've
always kind of played music,
I've kind of dabbled in it.
I don't have any
official training really.
I took a weird path
to music in the sense
that I never really
liked lessons.
I really didn't -- I felt
like they ruined music for me
for better or worse and so I
never was trained formally,
I just kind of like
learned on the side.
Kind of in secret actually
because I didn't want people
to know that I played and
then have me play for them.
>> Jennifer Cutting: Ah.
Did you have anyone who kind
of showed you a few chords?
>> Elena Lacayo: Yeah,
yeah, yeah, yeah.
My dad showed me some mariachi
stuff, you know, taught me how
to play like, "Happy
Birthday" and then he wanted me
to learn all this mariachi
stuff, which I wasn't interested
in at the time and
then I had, you know,
my friends from high
school or in middle school
that were playing like
Nirvana and stuff.
So that was my start and then I
started writing music probably
at the end of high
school with a friend.
But I had very few songs
until I was maybe 22.
I had already graduated college
and then I started writing
more songs in D.C. actually,
when I had moved here, and then
I just, you know, I kept playing
and people kept supporting
it so then I formed my band
and we've been together
for about six years now.
>> Jennifer Cutting:
Is it a staple lineup?
Has it been the same
lineup for all six years?
>> Elena Lacayo:
Well, it's D.C. so no.
>> Jennifer Cutting: Right.
>> Elena Lacayo: Well, at first
I started playing actually
with some of my buddies who
were in the punk scene here.
So that's kind of
more where we --
you know, that was kind of
these scene that I knew.
There's not a ton of -- I
mean there's a growing --
a small but growing
scene of Latino musicians
that make their own music.
I mean there's plenty
of musicians that kind
of reinterpret other people's
music and in traditional styles.
But in terms of writing original
music I think we might be,
I mean among just a few
bands, and so but Danny,
Danny who is playing with
us tonight, Danny Herrera,
he's an original member.
He started playing with
me a long time ago, 2011.
And he grew up in
L.A. in Pacoima,
California where Ritchie
Valens was from, and he grew up
and totally immersed in mariachi
and son jarocho culture.
And so actually we're going
to have the opportunity
to showcase some of
his talents in that,
which we haven't been able
to do as a band before.
>> Jennifer Cutting:
That's great.
>> Elena Lacayo: So he's
going to do Zapateale today
with the tarima, which is a
wooden stage where people kind
of stomp and it's a percussive
instrument in son jarocho.
And actually, funny enough,
he's going to be doing a rhythm
that men don't typically do
because the rhythm we're doing
is more like a [inaudible],
there's kind of different
words that are associated
with the rhythmic styles
and so on, jarocho.
And that's typically a women's
dance and so he's been trying
to learn it in time for
it and we were like,
That's cool we're
bringing, you know,
breaking stereotypes
it's fine so.
>> Jennifer Cutting: And you're
known for social justice,
music on social justice themes.
>> Elena Lacayo:
Yeah absolutely.
Yeah, that's one of
the things that we do.
I mean when I first moved
to D.C. I cam to work
on social justice issues.
First I worked for the Nuns
that are now known as Nuns
on the Bus network and then I
fell into working on immigration
and immigration reform.
And I did that for
a number of years
until I stopped to pursue music.
>> Jennifer Cutting: And
you pay a lot of benefits.
>> Elena Lacayo: Yeah we play
a lot of benefits and a lot
of our songs are, you know,
social justice themed.
So you know, we wrote a
song about immigration
and we have kind of
like a movement song
for recent political
events and stuff like that.
And I've been very
involved in and you know,
this is actually
one of the songs
that we're playing is
a bilingual version
of This Land is Your Land
and part of the reason
that we selected it is because
I've actually been playing it a
lot when I go I often get
asked to play at rallies
or different actions here
in D.C. The biggest ones
that I played were
against the Muslim ban,
the so called Muslim ban
when that was going on.
And one of the songs that I
found to be really resonate all
of the audience is "This
Land is your Land",
which is fundamentally
a social justice song.
When it was originally
written Woody Guthrie wrote it
because he was a
migrant himself.
Internally he was
originally from Oklahoma,
moved to California and
apparently faced a lot
of discrimination for that and
so he wrote this song to show
that this country is
actually a welcoming place.
And so I think that
it's really --
the reason it resonates is
because that sentiment is felt
again and again, unfortunately,
but also the sentiment that
we want to push back on kind
of like xenophobia, or you
know, unwelcoming sentiments.
And so it was one of the songs
that when we were doing all
those actions I thought people
most resonated with.
And So I really loved the --
so I'm doing a kind
of a combination,
Zonas de Mexico version, which
is a group that I actually saw.
I actually saw them
for that concert.
>> Jennifer Cutting: For
that concert they were here.
Zonas de Mexico ensemble
played here
for Hispanic American heritage
month in September of 2015
and during the concert they
did Esta Tierra Es Tuya.
>> Elena Lacayo: Yes.
>> Jennifer Cutting: And
also this song appears
in a much earlier form in our
collections in a manuscript
in a little mimeographed
bunch of papers,
which is called Woody
Guthrie's Ten Songs.
And it's in the Woody
Guthrie manuscript portion
of the Alan Lomax collection.
>> Elena Lacayo: Cool.
>> Jennifer Cutting: So
you're actually doing a song
that appears probably more times
in our collection that that
but we have it in manuscript
and then we have the recording
of "Zonas de Mexico" doing it.
So it's kind of a double whammy.
>> Elena Lacayo: Yeah, and
that's why I love the song.
I mean it just resonates.
Everybody knows it.
Everybody feels good about it.
But a lot of people
don't know about the kind
of the justice background
that the song has.
I don't remember exactly how it
goes in English but, you know,
the general translation of the
-- I know it more in Spanish
but there's one verse that says,
"When I came upon a big wall
there was a sign there it said
'No Trespassing' but on
the other side it didn't
say nothing."
And Zonas De Mexico does
it and they kind of make it
about the border, which
is what I really like.
>> Jennifer Cutting:
They restore that verse.
>> Elena Lacayo: Right, they
bring it back and we're going
to do that verse today as well.
>> Jennifer Cutting: So one
of the songs that you chose
from our collections you kind
of all ready knew and that made
that in a way easier to put
the work in on some other songs
that you didn't all ready know.
So the two other songs
that you chose, one was --
I remember looking
at the catalog card
as you were listening to it,
"El Presidente Wilson
me puso in Ordenanza."
>> Elena Lacayo: Yeah.
>> Jennifer Cutting: And
I remember you saying,
"Well I kind of like this one."
What about that song
sparkled at you?
>> Elena Lacayo: I just thought
like, what is this about?
This is a song to an
American president in Spanish.
You know, I thought
that was, you know,
it had to have an
interesting story.
And so as you indicated
it's a really old archive.
It's from 1934 and
it's basically
about the Tejano
experience of going through
and getting recruited to
be in the draft and a lot
of people deciding that going
to Mexico is a better idea
than going into the draft.
And so --
>> Jennifer Cutting: And
this recording is from John
and Alan Lomax recording
in Cotulla, Texas.
>> Elena Lacayo: Oh
is that where it is?
>> Jennifer Cutting: In 1934
>> Elena Lacayo: I couldn't -- I
was trying to look up the place
and I couldn't figure it out.
Cotulla.
>> Jennifer Cutting: And
it was the man who sang
in our field recording was Jose
Vallo and he played the guitar.
>> Yeah.
>> Jennifer Cutting: Now
what did you do with it?
>> Elena Lacayo: Well the guitar
part is kind of a Cumbia rhythm
and so we're like,
"Let's just dress this up
and make this a full Cumbia."
And so you know the
base them "boom, boom,
boom, boom, boom" you know?
And we put it in a key
where I could sing it.
>> Jennifer Cutting: Of course.
>> Elena Lacayo: And we
put some fiddle licks in it
and we just kind
of built the song
and it was actually
really fun to do.
So it was a really
cool experience for us
but we still stayed true to
like the, you know all the words
that -- well, I mostly
understood all the words.
There was a couple that I was
like, "Well just put this word
in here because it makes sense."
>> Jennifer Cutting: But that's
the same thing that happens
if you hear a song
that someone sings
and you don't understand
the words.
>> Right, right.
And that's how songs
evolve of course.
>> Jennifer Cutting: Right.
>> So it was really
cool to bring
to a song from, you
know, 1934 back.
You know?
>> Jennifer Cutting: Yeah.
And you were saying that
you probably not a lot
of people had heard it, right?
>> Yeah.
>> Jennifer Cutting: No, in fact
nobody has translated it before
you did.
And you've made a translation
for us that's now
going into our files.
So see you're going to live
in the archive forever.
>> Elena Lacayo: Fancy.
>> Jennifer Cutting: Not only
with your performance tonight,
with your translation
of "El Presidente Wilson
me puso in Ordenanza."
Which means?
>> President Wilson, I
guess he drafted me --
he put an order out --
he sent me an order.
>> Jennifer Cutting: OK.
>> Elena Lacayo:
He's drafting me.
>> Jennifer Cutting:
And the next song
that you have chosen
to do, "Cenzontle"?
>> Elena Lacayo:
Yeah, Cenzontle.
>> Jennifer Cutting: That was in
our collections as a performance
from the Home Grown
Concert Series performed
by Los Angeles Chicano
band [inaudible].
And they also were here
for Hispanic American
Heritage month.
But they were here in 2011.
And so tell me what about
that song attracted you
and then what you did with it?
>> Elena Lacayo: Woo.
Yeah, well that song
is really cool.
I mean [inaudible] is a group
that I have actually been
interested in for a long time
but I've actually not put any
effort or time into listening.
I've always -- you know, when
you have the list of groups
that you want to listen to and
they definitely were up there
and I definitely --
when I started --
I decided kind of that
I wanted to do a song
from [inaudible] partly
because they had the same kind
of instrumental lineup.
And also because thematically
they do a lot of similar things
than what our band is --
you know, they're very justice
oriented and they're based
in Son Jarocho, which is a
rhythmic pattern that I'm not
that familiar with
but I was like,
I'm willing to grow in this way.
And so Danny being the kind of
the person that knew the most
about the style of music taught
me the strumming pattern,
which I'm doing my
best to do on guitar
and we basically are
going to do it similar
to how they're doing
it in the recordings,
which it's a complicated song.
It's not the easiest song
in the world to learn
but I was really excited
about the challenge
and the band was at well.
>> Jennifer Cutting: Is that one
that you did during sound check?
>> Elena Lacayo: Yeah,
that's the first one we
did during sound check.
>> Jennifer Cutting: Yeah,
oh that sounds great.
>> Elena Lacayo:
Yeah, thank you.
And so Danny as I mentioned,
Danny is going to be dancing
on the tarima for that
part and that's going
to be really exciting
portion for that.
So we're all kind of
pushing ourselves in a way.
You know, this has been a really
great project for our band
because we don't tend
to do a lot of covers.
We don't tend to interpret
a lot of people's music.
That's more, you know, Danny
is definitely he has another
project where that's the
majority of what he does.
I'm more of a song writer that
tries to interpret my own stuff.
And so having the challenge
of like not only kind
of academically going into
archives and finding stuff
but also interpreting things
that I didn't right has
been really interesting
and a cool way to
grow as an artist.
>> Jennifer Cutting: Well that's
why it's called a challenge.
>> Elena Lacayo: Yeah, it
definitely was a challenge.
>> Jennifer Cutting: And
you've stepped up to the plate.
You've stepped up to the plate.
I'm really looking forward
to hearing the full versions
of all of these songs.
I want to thank Elena
Lacayo for being with us
at the Library of
Congress tonight.
>> Elena Lacayo: Thank you.
>> Jennifer Cutting: For
the Archive Challenge
Sampler Concert.
>> Elena Lacayo:
Yeah, thank you.
Thanks for having me.